good morning millennials welcome back
into the morning toast
happy friday friday
i'm so honored humbled and excited to be
sitting down with
one of my best friends celine dion's
number one fan
the best dog dad in the world and
world-renowned travel expert
brian kelly the point sky hello brian
thanks for having me you can also add
world class equestrian
yes you are just so dynamic like your
resume keeps building and like
you weren't you were just you're the
person who did quarantine right like
you know you got i shot myself how to
like ride horses and now
i actually in the car right here was
like should i get a grand piano for that
end room in my house so that we can just
tickle the ivories well that end room
is like such an elegant room that nobody
sits in because i think i need to get a
grand piano
i think janet can be in her gowns draped
over well let's talk about it let's talk
about the elephant in the room okay
janet is not here for those who follow
brian on instagram know that your best
friend
john pasta fazzullo pasta fazulo also
has you know an alter ego
janet he does drugs sometimes he's a
chef he's really everything of the sort
and he's kind of eclipsing you like you
really made him like a star
of your instagram stories yeah so people
always just say oh your friendship
is so sweet and he's so nice i mean he's
lost weight he shares like
his cooking is amazing so we were in
miami at the end of march and people
were coming up to him on the street
and they would be like like i don't
really care about you i'm not like
so john and i love it i love john should
be a star agreed
you know he's ready to burst yeah and
i'm like you know being the dean of
lohan like get out yes
you are stage moms like you are one of
those moms from toddlers and tiaras
absolutely
but i'm concerned now because i'm also a
star and he's eclipsing me and all the
toasters today were like
where's like we're so excited to have
john on the toast
and i saw you driving into the city with
john in the car and i thought it was
like a surprise for me that john was
going to be here
but he's not here yeah well i this is
it's been too long since i've been in
the studio i know
next time i think you should just have
john on the toast so people can get to
know him where he's hysterical he's the
best friend
he's the type of friend we never fight
yeah we always cry i've thrown my back
out crying
laughing with him and we have so many
like silly little jokes but if we're
being honest there's only one for two
stars in the show
there are and you know from the first
time i came on the morning breath when i
bought
brought you that there's a rhizome you
set me up
i did i thought about it this is dead
ass disgusting like it's really nice
it's kind of like a french vanilla okay
wait
give it another go it's like so
disgusting i can't believe you would
feed this to me
but i think it's really interesting that
you brought that up because part of my
whole journey into starting to drink
coffee
has to do with you because when you go
to brian's house in pennsylvania your
fridge is always fully stocked you also
have
if you guys ever saw extreme couponers
you know people downstairs they have
like their stock room
you have a stock room like you are fully
like a horse but it's like full price
custom egos
and it's elegant as [ __ ] like some of
these these um rooms on extreme
couponers
are so disgusting you would die no like
yours is very elegant and your room your
fridge is always stocked and i'm always
trying new things at your house janet
cooks for us and i drank a coffee one
morning i was just like hungover and i'm
like i don't know what i need right now
but i think it's a coffee
and i didn't never drink coffee and it
was so delicious yeah the starbucks cold
brew
with some almond milk i had half and
half obviously yeah
it was so good i'm like i think i need
to do this more often and i keep trying
to replicate that face it's the story of
our friendship i mean being in
uh the bvi's i couldn't believe claudius
snorkeled for the first time
i had never seen you were always
teaching me new things it's such a
pleasure to travel with you but to also
be your friend because you're
so like cosmopolitan and you're so well
traveled and you're just like
a man of many you've lived so many lives
and it's been about the truth ain't that
the truth and so it's been a journey to
just like
be a part of your journey and we
snorkeled we had the best time it was so
so much fun i thought it was like crazy
like oh my god like the craziest thing
and brian like the day before had went
like deep-sea diving like with an actual
whale
and the only whale we saw that day was
me and the number one question claudia
had while we were snorkeling
do you think meghan markle has snorkeled
it's a good of course who hasn't
i would say 95 of people in the world
have snorkeled i don't think that's true
you're a well-traveled girly i was a
little surprised no i know but like i'm
very much like a park your ass on the
beach during a vacation girly
not you like i never sat in my hotel
room the whole time we were out we were
doing this we were going bar
we go to this bar we're taking a boat
we're on like beach drop we actually had
a we had a
we didn't put it on instagram because it
was too much we still haven't actually
processed it together we had a cartagena
moment
on the boat coming home from the soggy
dollar and the bvi's amazing bar
amazing it took about an hour to get
there it was nice and kind of five
minutes like it was super fast
for some reason going home we took the
wrong way around the island it took two
and a half hours
the rain was pouring in the pitch black
we all had to pee
it was it was a trying experience we all
had to pee so literally we stopped the
boat
we actually had to stop the boat we all
were just it was actually so unfair like
the boys like literally just peed off
the side of the boat like all of us were
like hanging off of this ladder the
girls didn't get into the water
no i literally had to pull down my pants
and like hang over a ladder it was the
hardest yoga
no it was the hardest yoga i've ever
done though like i was not in shape for
it
erica who we were with like is an
amazing like she's like one of the
founding
boxers at rumble she's in amazing shape
for her it was nothing like this
position
for me i think i threw my back out
um so we have a great show for you guys
brian is here we're obviously we have a
bunch of stories they're a little
different because i want to talk to you
about some of the happening
happen happening on in the travel
industry but then also
you're a housewife connoisseur
encyclopedia and there's a lot going on
in the world of housewives like they're
in turks and caicos right now
we are gonna get into it and then at the
end of the show um
just because you're such a hard man to
find like we have you here we have to
ask you like a million questions
about travel about points the toasters
have so many questions for you so
if it's oh if it's all right can we dive
into the fast fast stories
let's do we have your permission without
further ado it is time for the past five
stories that you
need to know before you wake up and take
a bite out of your morning toast
and today's episode of the morning toast
is brought to you by olive and june we
are very very excited to be partnering
with olive and june the best at home
manicure on the planet
olivia gave me an olive in june salon
kit like
literally three years ago i still have
it it is the best nail polish the best
tools if you're looking to do a manicure
at home
it's virtually impossible to do your
nails yourself i know you've tried i've
tried and they look like they've been
painted by a five-year-old
but manicures at the salon can be
expensive because they always chip it's
just like not an ideal situation
and that's why you've got the olive and
june manicure system and now you know
why diy manny's
that looks salon perfect and always
lasts over seven days
so the kit comes with everything nail
buff nail file they have this great
little
attachment for the top of nail polish
bottles that steadies your hand
they've really thought of everything and
if you're looking to um
have an at-home salon experience that
doesn't look like a six-year-old did it
like theo painted your nails
check out olive in june their polishes
are stunning like pastel
dreams and with the mani system six
polishes come with it it breaks down to
just two dollars a manicure
and if you used to spend like 20 to 35
dollars on a manicure it's obviously a
no-brainer
it is a secret behind it behind nail
salon perfect nails at home
no guessing no messy nails no salon
price tag now you can get 20
off your first mani system with code
toast again your new nail life is here
get 20
off your first manny system when you use
the promo code toast at oliveinjune.com
if you're done with bad expensive
manicures this is the new one
check it out olive and june.com promo
code toast
i actually really have been using that
for a while it's fabulous um all right
let's dive in because the housewives
world is quaking i'm sure you know
all of the all-stars are in turks and
caicos now do we think kim richards is
going to show up as
like brandi glanville said that she has
not heard or spoken to
kim richards since december since new
year's eve so
i know that's not exactly that's very
worrisome yeah but kyle did go alone
jesus christ looks amazing
that's what is that some crafty face
tuning no well they all the housewives
physical face tuning like surgery faces
yeah right the housewives are literally
queens of like normalizing insane face
tunes
let's talk about teresa judicia i just
saw a photo of her it's
almost unrecognizable she
does edit her picture so much which is
so crazy because
in person like she's stunning and like
snatched
remember she was a bodybuilder but she
and she by the way she is on this
trip all the all-stars have jetted off
they are getting ready for a wild ride
what are they like i just understand
they're going to get four episodes out
of this
it's for peacock and color me skeptical
i would love to hear your thoughts on
this
candy say that once they start doing
all-stars it's all over
yep but here's who's on it and i would
love to hear like who your dream cats
would have been
because we have melissa melissa and
teresa from jersey
ramona and luanne from new york kenya
and cynthia from atlanta
kyle richards from beverly hills so we
have no dallas no potomac no salt lake
city oh
and it's mostly like oh geez if not
pennies
but i think they made a huge mistake i
think that's such a snooze cast
like you got to bring in fan favorites
i mean starting with karen huger karen
huger and the turks and caicos
i mean you don't even she could be the
only cast i am obsessed
that's why so just manifesting into the
universe that karen huger
we have dm before and i did as you know
buy her perfume
you are the number one wholesale
representative for la donna
i've loved karen hugo from day one i'm
not one of these new i did not and you
were like claudia you're so wrong you're
so wrong and i'm like no i don't see
what you see
but in the last two seasons i have done
a complete 180 you were 100
right yeah so yeah i mean i would also
pull phaedra dorinda and nene
like that's a cast the hard thing about
all these i actually think we should
have like
the fire and slash yeah the fire to
housewives island that would be like a
whole separate spin-off like
carlton jeb yeah oh joyce gerard
no now you're going a little too far
with joyce yes i agree i agree yeah
but the thing is with like all these
housewives it's like these ones
specifically who actually got cast are
so like you know ramona like they think
their [ __ ] doesn't stink
i can't imagine kenya and some of these
women like wanting to hang out with
ramona
yeah she's not a woman who's kenya is
also who wants to hang out with kenya
not me i actually kind of like her this
season i do not like
because drew is just so moronic i'm
sorry
i like her as a person but the final
storyline about the prophet is probably
one of the worst
most scripted cringe-worthy and you're
gonna hinge the season finale
on a prophet texting a friend of
that's all we got atlanta that is so
true
and drew is like being like taking it
really personally
but i cannot stand kenya like nothing
she could ever do would make me like the
season of housewives like season as in
so jersey's pretty good i like jersey
but like atlanta and dallas is so
like those two are oh they need some
reboots dallas
but jersey is maybe the best season
literally this season of dallas was
watching brandy redmond embrace her
inner karen
yeah and that's a journey i didn't want
to go on no and they do have really good
gems on dallas that don't get enough
shine like stephanie holman
cameron wescott is stellar cameron has
grown on me so much me too
and deandra like she's a queen i love
d'andra honestly i could
tiffany moon actually brings a lot to
the show her house is
sickening like if nothing else she
brings her husband must
because that's not a doctor's house like
that is some she's an anesthesiologist
i think he's a tech entrepreneur or
something i think he is too because they
have that like winery of three moons for
fun like
i i don't know i like tiffany moon but
she has thrown her mother
under the bus hit it in reverse hit it
back
in and the poor mother is just like i
worked hard to put you
you know and it's i get the pain or
whatever but
as a storyline i'm like okay stop
reversing over your mom she's so sweet i
couldn't agree more me and i had lunch
with taylor strecker yesterday we were
just talking about housewives
and she said wow she really threw her
mama to the bus i'm like i literally had
the same thing
it's a crazy thing to go on the show in
your first storyline like you're
literally just going to throw your mama
to the bus
who came to this country and probably
suffered so much to give you a better
life like
i totally agree what is your take on the
atlanta so when drew had that
awkward conversation with her young son
with the camera crew
with his father like look i get you sign
up to a show and you want to show your
all but
i kind of was team kenya there where
it's like oh god we were all like
it's already a difficult conversation
you can put boundaries i think any good
housewife should put boundaries or when
it comes to kids
it's like how dare you talk about my kid
and then they're putting their kids
front and center
for people to talk about but how dare
they and then like then the kid
automatically becomes
fodder for like social media and that's
not fair totally and that poor kid he's
so
cute and he's just like saying it over
and over and over and mommy wants a
different response for the producer who
was
clearly you know it's it was painful
painful i'm fully in agreement if you
don't have enough material in your life
and you have to use your kids on
housewives yeah it's not maybe it's not
the show this might not be for you no
and it's crazy because like children are
such like a lightning rod in certain
franchises like
jersey we're going through this thing
right now
thinking about so many things can you
believe how viral that went oh
because we six years ago when it came
out we would always joke about that and
we've been knowing about it like
the world and then we also love when geo
was coming home from camp it's
torture and torture
we need to like that will become the
next tick tock viral first he will won
then you would too then you were three
iconic lyrics
from the lyricist you should maybe do an
album of
covers of housewives moments not
housewives songs no
housewives moments you put a little
vibrato in yes i love that i
do melania's song too i mean that song
was good yeah
come on stephanie like in that music
video that music video where gia judice
buys them and theresa buys them that
board game that they all like jump into
iconic that was actually a really high
quality music video
so i i definitely we're obviously going
to watch this yeah because what else do
we have to do
but but i'm nervous i'm nervous too
because
these women are so into themselves
because they're they all think they're
the star of their franchise and the fact
that they got selected for this
all-stars makes them even more can we
talk about luanne
holding the center apple what well
that's actually a great segue into the
next story because sonia morgan is
calling bs on luan's deliceps claim
about her shocking new neighbor so
luanda de la sapps may have bought a new
apartment but her co-star sonia morgan
isn't buying her [ __ ]
about her new neighbor in a trailer for
the new season dilla sepps claims to
have been
shocked when she moved into her new home
only to discover that she had a direct
view of her ex-husband tom dagostino's
terrorists
during a panel at the paley center for
media in association with the new york
post
sony morgan said i'm gonna call bs on
that one because i live two blocks from
tom and i knew very well when we were
friends
and when she looked at an apartment a
block from my place she knew where tom
lived so here begs the question why
would she be shocked
like do you think she knew well i don't
understand she knows where
she used to live right and she knows
where she just bought it
place in new york city it's pretty
simple you know which streets
align to what so that's no no i'm going
to call it my favorite
term these days is calling it moronic
yes you've said that already
by the way every time i hang out
misbehavior that's what i call people's
every time i hang out with you i start
to talk like literally all i say now is
things are twisted
unique that's my other one when
something is like you just say oh that's
unique yes that's impossible you unique
so honestly hang out after people listen
to this episode they're gonna start
talking like you because every time i
spend the weekend with you i
come back and i talk completely
different i also i'm very influenced by
the rupaul's drag race of it all which
we also need to talk about like the
finale
your thoughts so i was team simone all
the way i
kind of i mean i just love i i mean my
most controversial opinion rose
is just not that talented like yeah he
shows up to work he can do it
but rose's mug like in rupaul's drag
race you've got to have it all honey
you've got to
transform you've got to have that star
quality and rose
certainly is talented but nowhere near
the others and in his mind i just think
he was so like entitled
yes and it was like kind of in my
opinion i was like he's getting along
like it's like
kind of like the white privilege of drag
like just because he's been in this like
family that supported him and that's
amazing but i don't know compared i love
candy muse rising from the bottom
like i just love a breakout story
dripping with
charisma and personality uniqueness
unique i completely agree with you i was
just more so on team comic
got mick is iconic too like first of all
such style like it's unbelievable but
then i find a lot of the queens who are
very stylish and very fashiony like gigi
good
really don't open up and and got nick is
an amazing comedian
and everything actress music like she
nailed she won snatch game
totally so although that i was like
simone was wrong someone was robbed of a
top spot for sure simone was robbed in
the snatch game and tina berner who i am
friends with
i love look i she didn't do as well as
she should have on the season but like
she should not have went home
i agree she was so robbed olivia
luxerone for so long olivia lux is the
most
boring no nice kid but like no
there was a concert i'm a diva you're
not a diva olivia lux
was like someone's kid that they didn't
want to send home because i couldn't
believe that olivia lux made it to top
five that was
an atrocity she must have had some like
secrets
on the network yeah like her dad is the
executive yeah like there's
something going on but it was a great
season like
maybe the best in a while um although
don't sleep on uk
and we in australia is coming out now oh
my gosh should be ready but the next
time you come to my house we'll have a
whole
everyone extravaganza everyone was
talking about you were like dying for
rupaul's drag race uk so i'm like okay
whatever i'll start it
and i'm watching it i'm like this is
like fine so i come over to your house
and i'm like it's good but like the only
queen who i'm like dying for is bag of
chips
and you literally turned to me you're
like claudia you are watching the wrong
season yeah
a season one was okay but season two is
amazing so i haven't had the time but
that's on my list of things and i will
also be watching down under
because i just love their accents oh my
goodness so good and like who do we
think is gonna be like the first
guest celebrity judge like and uh like
honestly danny minogue not kylie
danny honestly i was gonna suggest keith
urban we need like an australian icon
even though i don't know if keith urban
watches drag
but it's amazing on on the us i mean who
did we have this year anne hathaway
even remotely like they really killed it
yeah it's just such a good show and i'm
so glad like
it'll make you happy if you've never
watched rupaul's drag race just like
put it on and just enjoy the ride i'm
trying so hard to get jackie to watch
like
she would love it like the fashion is
sickening yeah but she just said her
content plate is full currently yeah
we'll see um so we believe sony morgan
when
she says yes luanne de la sept 100 knew
what was going on
um next up a little drama uh we're
coming full circle we reported earlier
this year about the whole lady gaga
drama which was so crazy
but the suspects in the dog napping case
have been arraigned thank god
the gang members alleged gang members
accused of shooting lady gaga's dog
walker and kidnapping her french
bulldogs were arraigned in los angeles
on thursday
james jackson who's 18 jaylen white
who's 19 and lafayette whaley who's 27
face attempted murder and robbery
charges for the february 24th dogs for
cash scheme according to prosecutors
jennifer mcbride and harold white are
charged as accessories to the crime so
this was like a full-fledged affair
there's five people on top of that
that's how terrifying i
and that dog walker is so cute by the
way i know
like after he gets better like i think i
slid into his dm's wishing him a speedy
recovery
are you like a fan of sliding into
people's cms
yeah from time to time um yeah why not
i mean because you're single now we
should also address the rumors
the the rumors are like are you dating
the rumors are you're no longer engaged
and you are dating janet pasta fazool
i'm not going to dress up
john pastor zolo is just my best friend
he's not even my but he's my sister
um so totally platonic um
and then yeah so i know i didn't you
know it was weird so i broke up with my
ex-fiance it was quick
you know we had gotten engaged in
december and
you know things started to get a little
i thought i was a little too idealistic
and thought oh everything will
you know having a wedding will make it
you know we'll get through it all we
actually did start going to some
counseling but i think it was a little
too little too late
right and then the pandemic hit and i
really remember thinking like okay i'm
leaving the city i had a lot of other
stressful things going on at the time
and um i just remember thinking i don't
want him to come quarantine with me
and i was like that's a moment when i
probably shouldn't marry someone that
i'm not willing to like
team with so yeah i made the decision
he's a great guy we still
are friends but um you know i i think
quarantine was
i needed to slow down i needed to hit
the reset button
i think my life before quarantine was
just like as the wise lady gaga one says
club club another club bus no
sleep airplane airplane jet flag jet lag
so
i was i always i looked back and i was
like i was on a hamster wheel that was
look so much fun i have zero regrets
i've gotten to see and do amazing things
but i was
out of whack i was just always exhausted
so yeah quarantine i didn't get on a
plane for 100 days i didn't have a drink
for 100 days
i rescued my dog you got a horse i've
had this beautiful house in pennsylvania
for years that i never actually
used because i would live in hotels and
i would sit there and be like i have
this amazing house that i've never used
like
how out of whack you know yeah you're
one of the few people i know who is
coming out of
cobin 19 not only 10 times
healthier physically mentally
spiritually like i think covid
and the quarantine in the lockdown was
the best thing for you like because
you're a totally different person like
you're so much lighter now
you know thank you i appreciate that i
mean it's definitely been a tough year
especially with the business you know
i started the points guy in 2010 and it
basically was a success from the
beginning
always profitable last year you know we
really you know business
overnight travel and travel and even i
just remember having these existential
thoughts of like what
is it safe to travel you know everyone
was hyped up and different people on
different sides of the spectrum so even
though i traveled safely and i believe
and still do believe in safe travel it
was tough
but it reaffirmed like to the core i
love travel i see that travel changes
people's lives
employs millions of people like so i i
think over the last year you know your
beliefs get
shaken but you come out of it even
stronger and
now luckily our business is booming
we're on an up
uh you said a million people are
traveling a day
over a million yeah the tsa so we're uh
basically at 65 of people going through
the tsa
versus pre-pandemic which is pretty
amazing considering europe's still
closed for the most part in asia
so that's why yeah domestically there's
going to be more flights
to mexico caribbean and q3 of this year
than there were pre-pending actually 33
more so the airline's going to mexico
everyone's going to mexico caribbean
florida gotta go yeah hawaii's out of
control right now so like you're just
like living
your best life now post pandemic and
that's not the case for a lot of people
so like i'm very impressed by you
thank you well i i'm fortunate enough to
have had this opportunity and now i just
i'm keep telling myself as the world
reopens don't mess it up don't
yeah literally and for me it's like girl
like stop drinking get your [ __ ]
together
um but back to lady gaga like as dog
moms ourselves this was a devastating
story like i think it's every person's
worst nightmare so i really am looking
forward to justice being served
totally and how crazy is that the woman
that returned it allegedly was involved
right like that was that whole thing it
was the whole thing was just so shady
like
when they returned the dogs to the
precinct i just don't understand why
they have to
shoot someone no totally like this like
you know there's five of you to
club them or something you know like in
general
totally like so unnecessary could have
just like knocked him out
no like there was a and by the way he
probably like tania hardy hit him in the
knees
yes embrace your entertainment heart
everyone can we stop shooting each other
that was terrible like it was a really
sad story and i think everyone thinks
like
it's your worst nightmare like i have
dog walker like it's literally
and i can see someone wanting to you
know die for theo like
feels stunning so theo like there would
be tons
of like drama over theo so like it's
scary that's why you don't want him
precisely that's why we just stay in the
house all day because i'm just too
afraid he's
i take him outside he's too beautiful
people are just gonna snatch him um
all right so we have two more stories
and they're a little bit more uh one of
them is travel focus for you but another
is
kind of the biggest news of the day josh
duggar being arrested which is brought
to you by skylight frames
a great way to feel close to people you
love is the skylight frame and people
keep signing into my dms
what is the code for skylight frames the
digital photo frame
please listen in the words of danielle's
dab pay attention
please staying in touch with those we
love is so much more important now than
ever
and the easiest way to do it is with
skylight a photo frame you can email to
photos to from anytime anywhere anyone
in your family can send
photos to the frame directly so it's a
great way to keep family members in
touch
it's super easy to use technologically
but if you have a parent or a
grandparent
who is not you know the most
technologically savvy you can handle it
all
yourself send photos of the kids of the
dogs it's really sweet
it takes less than 60 seconds to set up
effortlessly even for the least tech
savvy person it looks like a real photo
frame
and it adds beautiful touches to your
home the skylight frame has a gorgeous
10 inch screen where you can swipe
through photos with your finger
and even tap to thank the person who
sent the photo skylight frames offers
100 satisfaction guaranteed if you don't
love your skylight they'll offer you a
full
refund you can pre-load it with favorite
photos for special mother's day gifts
coming up this is your mother's day
reminder
do not forget you can surprise them with
photos they didn't even know that you
had you do it all from your phone it's
so easy
um it's a simple perfect gift for even
the least tech savvy person
now is a special holiday offer you can
get 10 off your purchase
of a skylight frame when you go to
skylightframe.com enter code toast
that's right ten dollars off your first
purchase at skylight frames
s-s-k-y-l-i-g-h-t f-r-a-m-e
dot com code toast for ten dollars off
your purchase
i'm just going to endorse that gift idea
because people say you're the hardest
guy to
shop for i'm like i don't want anything
physical get me pictures of my dogs
and my horses and i that's every time is
an amazing gift
and i walked through your home the other
day and realized there was not a single
photo of me i just realized what i'm
getting at skylight frame
and it's literally just going to be
pictures of me solo and then maybe a
couple of theo
yeah maybe some nudes tasteful nudes of
me in bed okay
kind of like the breaking news well i
guess when the q a comes up we'll talk
about our threat
yeah well we have to address those
rumors as well because the people are
quaking
um josh duggar has been arrested by
federal
agents in arkansas in the least shocking
news ever because we have been following
the torturous journey that is josh
jogger for the last few years
so they have arrested the former reality
star in his home state of arkansas
no details about the circumstances of
the 33 year old's arrest
have been released but u.s marshals
detained josh and placed him in federal
custody at the washington county
detention center
in the city of fayetteville yesterday at
one o'clock no bail was set the fbi had
no immediate comment when reached by e
news
neither josh nor his wife anna who
recently announced that she is pregnant
with their seventh child have commented
on his arrest
he has faced legal trouble before but
has never been charged with any crime it
is unclear if his past reported cases
are related to his recent arrests in
2015 as you know the show was cancelled
from tlc 19 kids and counting
after an unearthed expunged police
report from 2006
stated that josh duggar the reality star
was accused of molesting five underage
girls
when he was a teenager the victims
included four of his sisters
including jill duggar and jessa duggar
their parents told fox news that josh
their eldest child
had admitted to inappropriately touching
his sisters while they slept
he was never charged so of course now
we're all thinking well what did you do
oh
lord yeah this isn't going to end well
these stories just
are sad and if the fbi gets involved
like that's not your local police like
this is uh twisted
in your words and hopefully justice
hopefully
at least protect those kids i know and
there's so many of them
there's 19 kids and counting and then
all the kids have like seven kids
so they just keep multiplying and
honestly like he's always ever since
that story came up and he's been so
creepy and weird
and i know that the oldest daughter i
think i wanna they're all their names
start with jay and i don't know who was
who
but i believe jessa correct me if i'm
wrong the oldest one
has kind of separated from the family
and her and her husband are like very
um progressive and they're like
tick-tockers now and they're youtubers
and they talk about how like
you know they're really embracing you
know the lgbtq plus community so
the family's like all over the place but
josh is obviously like the black sheep
of the family but they always protected
him it's so weird like
what we need to stop doing is protecting
these like predators
[Music]
so bizarre um but it's also bizarre how
like there's no
charges like we don't know what he's
actually he could have like murdered
something like we're just assuming
but like when are we gonna know the fbi
is like being very tight-lipped about
this how dare they
how dare they it's like yeah no you're
100 right we deserve the information we
are looking forward to justice being
served
um and our fifth and final story is
coming from a very elite travel
website i don't know if you guys have
heard of it it's called the
pointsguy.com and the kind of like major
breaking news your instagram i'm sure
you've been doing like tv all week about
it um
the european union is expected to
welcome vaccinated americans this summer
so as of now if i wanted to hop on a
plane to italy could i
no unless you had like a business reason
or family
where you can go today is iceland greece
just opened although
we don't recommend going to greece until
the end of may when they actually open
up restaurants so that's the thing a lot
of times you can go to a country
but you may show up you're like what am
i going to do here there um so wait
until
the end of may june to go to greece um
croatia is also open i went to croatia
last summer yes
stunning and it used to be so crowded i
will say this like take your i've had
some of my best trips in the last year
you know going to croatia in august last
year when i was you know it was probably
10
and walking through the streets of
dubrovnik with the city to myself
versus eight years earlier when it was
jam-packed with cruise tourism
so but yeah this summer i was shocked by
that sunday when the
european commission president came out
and said that what she said was
it's open and if you're vaccinated
you'll be able to travel freely between
all 27
member states which is amazing um
it's interesting because in europe i
mean indoors you wear mass but outdoors
it's never been a thing which is kind of
smart
and like the cdc has even a great as
much like
um so yeah i mean i here's a couple tips
if you're gonna think about going to
europe let's wait a little bit to see
what the rules are i know a lot of
people also have unvaccinated
family members who can't get vaccinated
or 16 year olds and under who can't get
the vaccine what do we do well greece's
greece and croatia have already said you
can take a negative test so if you're
unvaccinated for whatever reason
or have kids you might want to plan one
of those destinations france yesterday
just said they'll be opening up june 9th
and then may 17th is when the uk opens
up
potentially um i talked to ceo of delta
ed bastian he
thinks that he's hot he's he's a really
great guy
when he comes up on the tv like with the
safety thing at the beginning of every
flight
i'm like damn that's a handsome man yeah
and he also gave up his salary to like
he's a he's a really like live for him
he's like an iconic travel industry
leader is he married
yes [ __ ] um in any case so for every
anyone who's like okay when do we book
so you can book now and you know i would
recommend later in the summer
as possible um but don't book basic
economy tickets so all the airlines you
know when you are in bvis you can change
your flights for free
it's amazing however of course not basic
economy tickets so
if you're going to book a speculative
ticket um i don't even
so you use it to book a ticket that you
can refund and most airlines will tell
you if it's basic economy
try to avoid that i would recommend
booking a base economy once we know the
dates the rules et cetera
do not book non-refundable hotels you
know book
book a refundable hotel because things
change all the time totally and you want
your money back you don't want to have a
huge voucher for a random hotel
in paris if for some reason they shut
down again but having a huge voucher
because like i just
i keep every trip i go on in the last
six months i end up extending just
because like i haven't traveled in so
long
and i don't mind getting my refund from
delta in the form of a credit like i'll
use it because you're rich but think
about people
who don't have the money to pay rent
you can't pay rent with the delta
voucher if you try so what's the best
way to get your money back from an
airline
so first and foremost i recommend use
your frequent flyer miles these days
because
in addition to free changes on paid
tickets most airlines now allow you to
get your miles back
fully free of charge so if you want to
just get that trip to mykonos on the
books
use your miles and then you can cancel
change whatever it's like buying a
refundable ticket okay
if not then uh you know if the airline
changes your
flight time by like an hour or two you
can call and request a full refund
they'll say no just take a voucher but
you can say no actually i want a refund
because the
and if the airline cancels your flight
you get you are entitled to full cash
refund
well you can also just ask too i
recommend being extremely nice delta is
probably the nicest of all the airlines
i know tons of people who during the
pandemic
were like i just can't travel and they
actually did full refunds
but you never get it unless you ask and
i recommend asking nicely
yes i agree with that it's very painful
to be at airports and see people who do
you
cancel my flight there's a tornado
coming but we could still you know right
like it's the [ __ ] gate agent's fault
like or you know tears of newsflash
people even if it's bright and sunny
where you are
where the plane is coming from might be
unsafe so it's like right
there's a million reasons and it's not
the gate agent's fault yeah yeah but it
also is frustrating to be a traveler and
like have your plans like just
sofa cocked and like don't you don't
know who to be mad at you know like you
can literally
be mad at noah um so are you going to be
traveling this summer
so right now i actually have a ticket
with you we were supposed to go to
israel in june and israel is interesting
they opened up but only for group
tourists now i do believe if you have a
group of people you can probably get the
approval to go or work with a travel
agent
by june when we're supposed to go they
may change it because israel's been
amazing with vaccinations they're like
they're almost like 100
so that i don't i'm 50 50 on whether
israel will happen
because we're supposed to go see celine
dion we are going so we started the
pandemic march 5th going to celine dion
front row at the barclays center
and it's only right that we end the
pandemic
mentally physically metaphysically with
seeing spiritually
we have to go like we have in israel
did you just get like chills down your
spine going to israel for me is like
such a spiritual experience already and
to see like the queen of my heart
would i tell you i don't know if you
ever recapped it but like the experience
of selena when celine was coming up to
claudia by the way
when celine we were front row of course
because brian brought the tickets not me
um and you know i've met celine a couple
of times she she toys with us she gave
me her sweaty and you're so
visible in a crowd because you're so
tall what how tall are you six seven
and i also wear like obnoxious versatile
shirt like literally like you could you
are so memorable and she literally you
said i think she remembers me and
when we went to the concert she a
hundred percent remembered you like
you're
unforgettable she like took her
wristband off rubbed it down her
chest and tossed it to me and i just
remember being like
then my relationship was like coming to
an end i knew kovan was going to turn my
life upside down it was like a full on
my life was out of control but i was
like i got this
celine looked me in the eyes and i was
like i can get and true story i started
the points guys because of celine dion
yes this is the best story tell them
real quickly so i've been a celine stan
since like 07 when i saw her
she had an album called taking chances
the song taking chances is iconic
listen to it right now it will if you're
ever thinking of doing something to push
you outside your comfort zone it's
literally she so anyway i started the
points guy in june of 2010 while i was
at morgan stanley
it starts taking off i remember like
people were like you're the points guy
and i was like oh my god this is so cool
i was like in my cubicle
blogging back when blogging was and um
so anyway i kind of it started to become
a thing i wanted to quit but everyone
was like brian you can't you're about to
get vp at morgan stanley you can't
leave stanley for a passion project yeah
[ __ ] craziest thing and i was walking
through times square i had an
out-of-body experience celine dion
taking chances played
i went into the cube or i went into the
elevator in times square went straight
to my boss's office i said i have to
quit and do the point sky full time and
she goes
hell yeah man high five and she's like
if it doesn't work back work out come
back instantly and i was like
oh my god in my head we always think the
worst yeah it's all or nothing
and it really taught me like okay like
we create these
crazy like sophie's choice in our head
when we actually have a lot more options
no but you're also like such a and what
i've really learned amongst many things
for me was like
you're so nice to everyone like you
build relationships with people you
don't care if they can
you know if they're you know the top of
the food chain or the bottom of the food
chain like you were just lovely to
everyone
so of course they would want you back at
morgan stanley because you're a delight
like who wouldn't want to work with you
thank you so much it's true no
it's really um but i think it's a good
message for people out there
like and trust me even at the points guy
like i've been you know being nice to
people gets you way further than being
a brat no and that's in your work life
but also like even at an airport like
if you're an [ __ ] like no one wants
to help you yeah there was a guy in high
school in college i was student body
president he created this iheartbk fan
club i thought he was a stalker kind of
weird
but i was always nice to him and then he
was the one truly when the points guy
started off he reached out to me and
said brian you're blogging about credit
cards i work for this marketing company
for amex and i can get you in
and because i was nice like i thought he
was a freak and didn't want to ever talk
to him but
i kept the relationship open and then he
changed my life by monetizing the blog
which
overnight was like oh my god this is my
path right and that's how you can
really afford to leave your job at
morgan stanley because a passion project
is fun
but if you're not making any money it's
just a passion exactly
but it's fabulous and celine dion
started it all taking chance and i know
toasters will always say like and other
celine dion songs that we love
imperfections
don't sleep on it it's amazing don't
sleep on imperfections or courage
courage yes brian i said to brian when
we went to the sling down concert i hope
she doesn't plan for new music because
like
sure it's great but like just stick to
the classics and brian was like no her
new album is like filled with
gems and she started to play a new song
and i was literally gonna go to the
bathroom and like go get some french
fries and brian was like just sit and
listen
i sat down i literally started crying
like it was
stunning because it's all about her
losing her husband and her son right
or she didn't lose herself or her mom um
and also
uh so imperfections is like the ultimate
breakup song too so i
listened to that song like 10 times a
day after i broke up with my fiance
no it's inspiring and then i also
recommend kim petrus
for when you want to throw the [ __ ] down
she is an underrated malibu
icy i don't want it all um listen to it
thank me later she actually did a uh
over the pandemic she did a virtual
concert for red ventures
and she nailed that she was so easy to
work with i love you kim petrus
and she's going to be a star she is a
student she is a star but like she
should be
ten times better and it's just feel good
music you introduce me to her as you do
all good things
um okay so i know you're a busy man and
i won't take you for that much longer
but
and i'm sure this happens to you all the
time like people just have a million
questions for you
okay so we're gonna do a little q a i
got questions on the instagram for brian
brought to you by jinx an online dog
wellness brand that offers nutrient-rich
all-natural
clean kibble meal toppers treats and
dental chews
delivering balanced nutrition in every
bite that arrives directly at your door
after all dogs have evolved from their
wolf-like ancestors they are 21st
century omnivores that require both meat
and plant-based nutrients which better
suit the lifestyle that includes a lot
more sleeping and a lot less hunting
our dogs nutritional needs have changed
but their food has not their
our dog's lifestyle and overall activity
level directly impacts what they eat
most foods have too much filler or
protein which means they aren't getting
the nutrients they need to thrive in
today's environment
jinx has created nutrition for the
modern dog with the right ingredients in
the right proportions for balance
nutrition in every bite
jinx offers a complete all-natural
nutrition solution for your pup
premium clean kibble it's powered by
superfoods backed by science
they have lean proteins with 20 plus
superfoods and a patented probiotic
they are pet nutritionist designed and
veterinarian approved
they are savory limited and real
ingredient meal toppers that provide
flavor and nutrient boost
at meal time is exciting even in the
picky seeder that's so true like we know
so much about our dogs i've done like
dog dna tests like
our food should be evolving for our dogs
and dogs are literally the most
important things in the world so if you
are not taking care of them
shame on you it is the world so jinx is
the world's first limited ingredient
all-natural dental chew
for daily oral care as well which is so
important because like i always forget
to brush my dog's teeth
but there's great breath theo has great
breath because he's just like shining
from the inside out he's perfect
his sparks don't smell either i don't
think they do really badly
so the website is thinkjinx.com so the
code is toast50 if you want to get 50
off your first order that's legit
thinkjinxjinx.com
code is toast50 for 50 off your first
order
um okay so i'm just gonna like rattle
off some questions for you because the
toasters are quaking
what do you think it's going to take for
the u.s to allow europeans to come
in um and come back and visit with
non-stop routes
um so i believe we'll hear an
announcement within the next week or so
from
our government i think we could be
letting europeans in as early as
uh mid-may that was the rumor we heard a
couple months ago
i think our vaccinations are you know
the numbers are under control
and look tourism is important but so
many families have been separated i know
and so for people who have been dating
someone abroad and can't see them
i'm very hopeful that families will be
reunited soon honestly like the pandemic
has been
so challenging for everyone but i cannot
imagine how like
painful it's be it to like not see
family like who lives in another state
or like a boyfriend like that's crazy
um also is it terrible to say like
because tourism is such like a valuable
economical thing but i've really enjoyed
like the city being just like
a little bit less packed is that bad
it's not bad
no i just have like it's so quiet but
like come on this 12 p.m curfew no
brian they it was 11 p.m and then cuomo
was like 12 p.m and are we supposed to
be grateful like
i'm like girl like but july what's your
life for now in new york july 1 they say
like
completely open i don't know what that
means because it feels like we are
opening i just want to live in
pennsylvania in june
100 i just bought i yeah we can get into
that later we'll get into it
um okay so whatever i tell people like
about because points are very confusing
but the biggest thing that i've learned
from you is like
not to use those portals is that correct
like the chase portal
well look the chase portal at you know
if you have a sapphire reserve you're
getting one and a half cents a point i
actually use it now because i have so
many points when i stay at hotels in the
city because i actually gave up my
apartment because i'm barely here
anymore
so it's not the worst but the best value
in general is when you can transfer to
airlines and book first class seats
but considering international travel is
so much down look the old worlds are out
the window use your points
they're going to go down in value
because there's so many points so fewer
flights so just use your points and be
happy with it just don't let them
stack up do you get motion sickness no
any type of like no boats no i got boat
sickness
once never got it again never been sick
on a plane
um i used to be really afraid of heights
not on an airplane but like even down
here like a ledge
like it like queasy or whatever have you
ever skydived no but i did hang gliding
in south africa off of signal hill which
would i did it with my dad
he went first with his and we just
floated through the air in cape town
over the ocean we saw like a whale jump
wow
we both it was one of those experiences
i was scared shitless horse
but like kelly clarkson said what
doesn't kill you makes you stronger no
and we got down on the ground it was
like i hugged my dad
oh my god your dad is so cute and his
name is also brian kelly senior
are you brian kelly jr no we have
different i'm christopher kelly he's
patrick kelly
you guys are so irish it's hilarious and
by the way this irish cream is delicious
i'm glad you're enjoying it because i'm
not
um is there a risk of traveling with
kids and them catching kovid
yeah so one of my colleagues just took
his kids to spring break in the bahamas
and his six-year-old got tested positive
for kobe
and so they had to stay in their house
they couldn't they were on this
beachfront house and they couldn't leave
the house so yeah you had to like look
at the beach the whole day and you're
just like they literally couldn't even
go to the beach yeah so they had to stay
until she tested negative it's like 10
days
well a lot of hotels i saw this thing
luckily kids aren't getting sick but
right but i saw um the sls bahama which
is a great hotel for bachelorette
parties
is offering if you catch they're so
certain that they have the best covered
protocols that if you catch covid
at their property they will let you stay
for free for two weeks and fly you back
private to your house
well the private thing is a gimmick it's
like not actually
um but yeah a lot of hotels will either
give you 50 off like i'm i was
for sure like people are gonna get
covered just to get a free vacation
oh for sure no i literally when i heard
about the private jet i wanted to go to
sls and like lick the floor
but yeah a lot of hotels will help not
only just get the test but if it tests
positive
once you've spent all of your points you
have on a credit card what's the next
move you build it back up do you find
another card
get another card the card market right
now is the hottest i've ever seen it
there's like
80 000 points in the sapphire preferred
which if you're looking to get like an
intro card
that's the no-brainer card it's 95 a
year but you're getting those
eighty thousand points are worth over a
thousand dollars in chase travel
so there's no way you can possibly lose
but yeah once you use those eighty
thousand i mean yeah there's a million
and one other cards
you know don't just make sure when you
apply for a card you know you usually
have to spend three thousand whatever
don't apply for four and all of a sudden
you're like i need to spend 12 grand
this month so you recommend like one at
a time yeah go one at a time and look
look at your score your score will have
a temporary dip when you apply for new
credit but then it increases
but you must must must must pay your
bills on
time and in full and not they say like
you shouldn't
spend above half your credit limit yeah
i mean you just pay your bills in full
every month i mean because if you're
paying interest
the points that you're accruing are
going to be eviscerated by the interest
fees so right
to win at the game you gotta be smart
don't spend more than you
spend what you have yeah and what about
cruises like where are we at with
cruises
cruz is interesting they just announced
from the u.s the cdc starts to approve
it they kind of gave it
approval the other day but most of the
cruise lines are saying okay we'll screw
the u.s
they're going to leave from bermuda
jamaica barbados
and no no alaska cruises but there's
some european ones this summer
tbd they're supposed to be doing drills
this month and in june
like fake cruises where they you know
we'll see but cruising will come back
really not
meaningfully until 2022. i know but you
know what like
i feel like if well actually no that
makes no sense how many people usually
go on a cruise like i mean some of these
ships have 5 000 people
and the thing is testing as we all know
you know within 72 hours well great a
lot of things can happen within 72 hours
and the rapids like aren't 100 percent
reliable i mean my uh friend who i was
was she's fully vaccinated
she tested positive and then was freaked
out and then she went and got two other
tests and was negative because she had
just got the vaccine out
there's like these outliers but that was
like an at-home one that this company
had sent us so
it's the testing is still just don't
think yeah
just be careful with the testing um this
is a very good question that i had uh
where is it oh um can you give your
thoughts on the
the threbel yeah so you know ben's a
very caring guy
and you know i'm like normally the big
guy in the relationship yeah and like
once in a while it's just nice to be the
small spoon yeah
he's a really good spooner no and you
guys are both so
you know different but like well we have
the same joie de vivre
you know we both love food yes and yeah
just you know so ben and i connect on a
culinary level where me and you connect
on a sexual level very sexual yeah um
okay so cruises like you don't think
it'll be
because we got a lot of questions
nothing until next year really what's
the best
oh and you have to be vaccinated going
to cruise in general i have to talk to
you
because you always say and i've asked
you this and people always want to know
like
in your opinion what is the best um
commercial airline
in the states and you say well delta is
the best like run airline
jet blue that's what you said it's like
for everyday people
like like grooms snacks i was in florida
and i flew home jetblue and i really you
know i only fly delta but i was like
okay
like brian says jetblue is it jetblue
should be okay and honestly and this is
going to be crazy it was giving me
spirit airline vibes
how do you figure it first of all tvs
your free snacks there's tons of leg
room no it was first of all
it was just like ev okay it wasn't even
nothing was free and i was in extra leg
room of course what do you mean
nothing's free literally they walk
around headphones six dollars
headphones headphones are free no
claudia you haven't flown coach in a
while but
in coach you have to pay for headphones
and no
no they are not friends maybe on
international flights but every domestic
character
same because it had but it's not a jet
blue thing if headphones are not free
then my airpods should work with the tv
what are we going to get i've asked them
uh yeah it's tough
with the uh so many bluetooth
frequencies and then like the navigation
whatever
but then also but you can just bring a
plug like you know delta
doesn't serve fresca anymore can you
explain that well delta cut back a ton
so they were only serving beer wine
and water you know soda but i can get a
beer how does that make sense
no it's it's cost cutting at the end of
the day yeah you know like delta
blocked all middle seats which cost them
so they had to cut back extremely on
food but delta i have to say is like
really doing a fabulous job
with the seats like but may want to
starting may one it goes
it's now they're going to be booked full
so and
kind of the biggest thing to happen in
the travel industry which makes no
[ __ ] sense is the attack on dogs
no more emotional support what the [ __ ]
well
yeah it's tough for people who fly well
the problem is you know
this is why we can't have nice things
because people brought
they're turnt ass dogs that were not
trained
not well behaved and as well no it's not
the dog's fault yes
dumbass owners there's no bad dogs and
truthfully i mean the numbers show that
like there were twenty thousand dog
bites in the sky in like 2019
20 000. a lot of my flight attendant
friends are like brian
your dogs are great but like you don't
understand most people bring on their
wild untrained dog
yeah it creates a hazard it does so it's
a shame for all the people who like
have good dogs good dogs they're dogs
but there's always
morons yeah so but you can still
you can still fly with your dog like you
have to keep them in the carrier no you
should but
you know it to you have to look into it
um but you can still certify your dog as
a service animal there are ways around
it
so if you're very you know do a little
research
yeah not officially endorsing anything
but they're you know i see a lot of dogs
still in the sky
so it's so annoying i'm sure any toaster
will be able to figure it out
yeah catch my drift final question for
vaccinated americans what are currently
your top three places you would
recommend to travel
within the next couple of months taking
covered restrictions and regulations
iceland
iceland iceland i've been twice once in
july once in december so two extremes
loved it both times iceland used to be
overridden with tourists
it's empty i we had one of our employees
go last month when they opened up to
americans
it's so simple you bring your cdc card
you breeze through no testing
and it's like it's this card and they
can't use it it's so beautiful
like truly it is a mystical land of love
and it's like five hours it's like going
to l.a
it is yeah it's five hours away it's
like halfway to london like
that's like crazy i thought it was like
normally 12 hours no you fly over when
you go to europe it's so
beautiful highly recommend iceland i you
know croatia is
so beautiful sickening um and game of
thrones
and hvar so dubrovnik and split are the
beautiful historic towns
hvar h-v-a-r party town
it's where electronic music festivals
first started beach clubs
oh wow beautiful cool vibe toasters
we'll live in it yeah you will love
havar oh my god gotta get to havana and
also you can rent boats and go
there's all these croatian islands
stunning the food and it's pretty cheap
greece will be opening up um and then in
the u.s
the thing about the us is things are
packed like you know you're not going to
find a lot of travel deals to hawaii or
miami
you know i was in miami at the end of
march with 2 000 a night i was in
florida literally the airport was
pandemonium so what i would tell people
is you know if you're in good health if
you're vaccinated
go to iceland now take your girlfriends
you will have the best time of your life
no it's
you're right like take this time and as
an opportunity yes because
especially we were in the bvi's and it
was kind of torturous like so many tests
every day and
but it was so worth it because we were
at this hotel and dead ass like they
said it was 10 capacity
i swear to god we were the only people
there how cool i mean i loved it i
was having your own billion dollar
resort to like yourself it was so
special like and you'll never get that
so you're right and bvis are getting
much more relaxed may 15th if you're
vaccinated
you have to take like one test when you
arrive they almost didn't let me into
the hotel because like
my test results hadn't come back yet it
was true tvi's are very toasty yeah the
soggy dollar
it's so you know what post central i've
never been
but you're always going to the maldives
maldives and maldives are open
uh vaccine passport oh um and even if
your friends abroad
can't get vaccines maldives are going to
start offering vaccines to tourists
so you can go are people abroad having a
hard time getting yeah i mean it's
really slow in
some countries you can't when i was in
portugal my friend there was like my age
she's like
right now i'm scheduled for 2020 like
three yeah it's like really
slow um so yeah maldives are
sickening wow i didn't know that i feel
so blessed that we're just
use your points to fly like emirates or
qatar through the middle east to go to
the maldives
oh it's the best yeah and dubai is also
open i had so much fun in dubai over new
year's going to a kiss concert yes that
was that looked like tunisia
well thank you for lending us your
expertise i'm sorry to have taken you
for so long i hope you guys learned
something
and i just so um i'm honored and humbled
that you spent your morning with us at
the morning toast we are so grateful we
really are
see you this afternoon tomorrow tomorrow
night i'll see you tomorrow tomorrow
morning tomorrow night
we're having we're going out of bed
already you guys have an amazing weekend
thank you so much for listening to the
morning test millennial morning show we
deliver the fast fast stories that you
need to know every monday through friday
and youtube's ever watching us on
youtube please feel free to subscribe
and give this video a thumbs up we're
also available as podcasts and we're
podcasting we found so it's spotify
stitcher public radio i already all the
places wherever you listen to podcasts
find out morning chelsea five star
review about beautiful stunning and
smart we are follow brian on instagram
brian kelly at the point sky honestly
also on tick tock both accounts are
fabulous for all travel updates
have an amazing weekend don't drink and
drive we'll see you on monday bye